قال رئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون في
مقابله مع الجزيره ان العلاقه بين بلاده
والمغرب وصلت الى نقطه العوده اضاف انه
ياسف على وصول العلاقه بين البلدين
الجاريين الى هذا المستوى
صفه مختصره جدا
ثانيا يستخلص العبره في 60 سنه استقلال
الحدود مغلوقه منذ 43 سنه فيه اكثر من
دلاله واكثر من
جواب على السؤال تاعك كل حال وصلنا
تقريبا نقطه لارجوع
واحنا الموقف تاعنا رانا في رده فعل لن
نكون يوما ما البادئين بعيش
بشان موقفي اسبانيا من الصحراء اعتبر تبون
على موقف حكومه مدريد فردي من حكومه
سانشيز ومنحاز وذلك بتصرفات سريه لا
تعفيها عن مسؤولياتها وقال ان الحكومه
الاسبانيه احتناست انها القوه المستعمره
السابقه للصحراء الغربيه
ومسؤولياتها ما زالت قائمه
اسبانيا كان من المفروض تقعد في الحيط
في موضوع الصحراء الغربيه مش حاجه
بتصرفات
بما تعرفيهاش من المسؤوليه نتاعها وكانت
تصرفات سريه لانكم تستقبلت انا
الرئيس
تحدثنا في كثير من المواضيع لنا علاقتنا
مكثفه
وفي النهايه
ستقف معها راضيه من رضي وغضب من غضب وفيما
يتعلق بعلاقه بلاده بفرنسا وصف الرئيس
الجزائري في لقائه مع الجزيره هذه العلاقه
بالمتذبذبه وقال ان الشعب الجزائري يرفض
التخلي عن تاريخه وذاكرته مضيفا ان السفير
الجزائري قد يعود قريبا الى باريس
ان علاقتنا دائما فيها
ذبذبات
للماضي الاليم اللي عشناه مع بعض عشناه
132 سنه مع بعض كان فيه
يعني الامور سيئه جدا
والذاكره احنا شعب يخاف من التاريخ
ويسجل كل خطواته في التاريخ وما نتخلاش
على تاريخنا
الذاكره نتاعنا
سفير حتى نرجع يرجع لان في عنا جاليه
وعندنا يعني قريبا
لازم ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
وعن الازمه الاوكرانيه قال الرئيس تبون ان
الجزائر مؤهله للعب دور الوسيط كونها من
الدول التي تملك مصداقيه كافيه للوساطه
حسب تعبيره
ما بين دول القلائل اللي عندهم المصداقيه
الكافيه تخليهم وتخليهم وسيط تكون وسيط في
كثير من النزاعات حتى النزاعات اللي ماهيش
في افريقيا تقارن تاعنا ولا
نتمنى نتمنى باش
طرفين يكونوا قابلين
احنا حاولنا وسط على عربي
تتراسل الجامعه العربيه